in 2013 I had a life-changing epiphany I
was a painter and decorator in
Castlemaine a small country town in
central Victoria I'd gone to see Pete
who was renowned for his workmanship
with steel I'd gone to his shed to get
some steel edging for the garden this
day with hindsight which is a wonderful
gift
Pete seemed happier than usual two weeks
later I was painting a house down the
end of Pete's Street when I heard the
tragic news Pete had suicided Pete like
myself was a tradie or a tradesman we do
like to shorten things in the Australian
vernacular a tradie there was an
expectation as a tradie
you're expected to be stoic you're
expected to be strong robust macho you
expected to be tough physically and
silent in the face of adversity there is
a pronounced ripple effect when someone
suicides in your community Pete's
funeral was in July it was winter the
mood was bleak and sombre in the packed
community Hall it was a grieving
community who had no answers - Pete
suicide no answers at all as I wandered
around with the pits between the tradies
and the community members I started
hearing some tones of another underlying
tragic level I heard people talking in
that community hall about the struggles
other people were going through the
essence of the conversations was
contained in two words that I heard
several times
who's next who's next
that was the Epiphany that was the
moment where I was standing in a
community hall in a place where this
castlemaine community had given me such
support for 20 years this community had
backed my work I played footy there I've
done theater there I was so grateful for
what they'd given me but I was standing
there in that space and I was looking
around that hall as well and I could
tell people in that hall who are
struggling with alcohol drugs finance
gambling domestic abuse and bullying and
harassment yet because of my tradie
culture and that ignorant attitude that
we have in the trading community
I didn't felt confident I didn't feel
confident at all I didn't have the tools
I lacked the experience I didn't know
what to do but I wanted to do something
I left the wake I hugged a few tradie
mates and said please come and see me if
you need to but I didn't know what to
say to them or what to tell them I had
no idea I got a phone call two weeks
later from Catherine pilgrim my
co-founder wanting to do something for
the family we talked for a while I said
let's do something for the traded
community we love our town we're
grateful let's do something for the
traded community so we talked a bit more
what could we do and awareness raising
event awesome we're talking about
tradies how do you get tradies somewhere
you can get them to a hospital
No to a community health center no
there's a engrained culture being a
trading I thought where is the perfect
place we can get the tradies together
when they feel socially included and
they feel comfortable and they can share
they can open up and talk about mental
health the building industry where can
we have an event a hardware store yeah
that's what I thought so I thought was
very clever more precisely the timber
yard of a hardware store so there we
were okay we've got the
venu what else do we need what else do
tradies love food I know we all do but
tradies love food tradies especially and
I'm a trading myself
we love egg and bacon rolls so we
thought would supply the trainings with
egg and bacon rolls and there was the
slogan save your bacon it's a bit corny
but it sort of works and we also came up
with a logo hope assistance local
traders keep in mind halt
our charity had no money to begin
nothing not a single cent we had
conversations this is a community issue
it starts in community so we went around
to the butcher we went around to the
Baker
there was no candlestick maker there was
an egg place and there was some
chocolate there was coffee there was
fruits but we went around and said hey
we're doing this awareness-raising
events do you want to contribute could
haven't got any money
of course nearly every person we
initiated the conversation with knew
someone that had anxiety depression or
thoughts of suicide or had suicidal
there was that unity that whole of
community approach so we thought that's
great we've got some food what else do
we need we need the support services
there a lot of tradies and a lot of men
in general don't necessarily know where
to go and get help
I myself was one of them and this is
what I talked about at the halt events
that four years ago when I founded holt
I didn't know I could go to the doctor
about my mental health and get a mental
health plan I didn't know about
community health I certainly didn't know
about lifeline and I've called lifeline
three times and they've certainly
potentially saved my life I had to learn
all he sings tradies need to know that
we provided bags bags of information and
I had quite a few traders say to me in
the first year this is a load of you
know what
but those tradies I know still have
those bags in there you or in their shed
on the 10th of November 2013
we've had our events
and interestingly enough when I talk
about a whole of community approach that
was our first events in Castlemaine at
tongs Brothers and there's a whole of
community there there's counselors
there's people who have gone through
mental health that first event set the
scene since then we've had more events
interestingly enough it's not only
traders that are affected by mental
health or anxiety or depression or
suicide we started working with tapes we
started working in the farming industry
at councils at secondary colleges we
started working we did events for the
partners of tradies because often the
tradies would not go home to their
partners and say guess what we talked
about mental health and we're going to
do this this and this now so we're doing
events for the partners who themselves
may need help TAFE are very popular for
me it's really crucial to get to these
young vulnerable men and women we've
done events for men's sheds so the high
rate of suicide is really high for older
men we've done events for council Depot
workers and traders interestingly enough
nearly every single events and we're
actually done now with very little
funding a hundred and fifty events over
four states so oh please thank you
and invariably at every single halt
event at a hardware store I have one
trade he come up to me at least one come
up and tell me about his suicide attempt
they're not suicidal there and then
they've worked through it but these men
have never felt they could share their
vulnerabilities they've never felt they
can talk about their suicide attempt but
to halt events where there's no
expectations for them to talk makes them
feel comfortable to start talking and
that's not just they talk to me and tell
me their story they actually now say we
feel comfortable enough to talk with
other men I've had men stand up and say
I've never mentioned before that I've
had depression but I have and if anyone
else here wants to come and speak to me
I'm here to talk to you it's very
empowering and cathartic to do that we
need a whole of community approach we
give the tradies bags of information
from local and national support services
it's one thing to tell a tradie or
someone at one of these events you
should go here here and here but we need
the whole of community to wrap around
the idea of suicide prevention we need
those services and suicide doesn't
discriminate at all it's not a
nine-to-five thing we need to do events
before 9:00 a.m. which most of our
breakfasts are and after 5:00 p.m.
that's what we need to do it's a whole
of community approach we need to get
into businesses we need to get into
sporting clubs community clubs we need
to get in there and train people to
understand about mental health here's
some sobering statistics just to give
you an idea in 2016 in Australia 2866
suicides very close to twice the road
toll globally 800,000 a year
suicides in the world one every 40
seconds we need a whole of community
approach we need to feel comfortable in
opening up the conversations men I know
find it really difficult to open up
conversations
they certainly do if you're going to
open up conversations I tell the guys
you need to find a comfortable place to
open up and have a conversation whether
it's at the pub it's going for a walk
it's after 40 find that really
comfortable place to have the
conversation part of the ability to have
that conversation is to understand what
to say we've all heard about are you
okay and I've seen it I've done this are
you okay
yes are you okay yes are you okay yes
are you okay no what do I say now what
do I say we need to equip every single
person with the ability to come forth
and be able to have that conversation we
need to be able to listen I don't know
who out there is a good listener
I'm working on my listening abilities
but it's an art form to listen and not
judge don't make fun if someone's coming
to talk to you about mental illness and
anxiety and depression and thoughts of
suicide we need to respect that they
want to trust us that we're going to
hold that in tight and not tell everyone
we need to do that so we need to have
conversations we need to listen and we
need to start reducing the stigma
associated with mental health companies
now saying to have mental health days
what a great idea
it's not just physical sick days it's
mental health days things are changing
we can add to that change I'm a life
preserver I think we can all be life
preservers the pain of regrets is far
greater than the pain of hard work thank
you
[Applause]